[Aplausos]
eu acho que fotografia é uma coisa que
mexe muito com a questão da vaidade eu
falo a vocês agora vamos fazer uma foto
a mulherada toda vai correr pro banheiro
vai querer passar batom ou fazer
chapinha e vou demorar horas os homens
apesar de tudo não queria colocar a
gravata está tudo bonitinho e assim por
diante
quero fazer uma pergunta pra vocês a
fotografia é uma coisa que mexe muito
com a vaidade
a gente tem uma foto que é o tempo todo
na nossa vida a exposição que é o foto
do rg alguém gosta da foto do rg
o papa tem uma pessoa que com a
autoestima boa
agora quem não gosta
o é muito óbvio né e quem tem coragem de
mostrar a foto quando tinha até os 13
anos adorava essa foto eo orgulho de
apresentar o rg
hoje eu quero processar a minha mãe com
ela deixou eu sair eles falam desse
jeito
e hoje você pega o álbum de família pelo
amor de deus gente aquela coisa básica
né
apesar de tudo usando serem passado hoje
olha no espelho eu tenho realmente 40
anos de idade e eu vejo que o tempo
realmente melhor as pessoas
oque continuam baixe a mãe tem um
pouquinho de peso só um pouquinho
coisa pouca e os cabelos foram ficando
branco assume os meus bancos e gosto
deles
e tudo isso eu quero dizer para vocês o
que que a beleza é uma coisa relativa o
que ontem pra mim era bonito hoje não é
a começar pela minha auto e matt
referência de beleza nós temos no
período da história vários momentos da
alemanha ou o suas curvas no cinema anos
40 era referência de beleza hoje é
anoréxica ícone 20 o tudo bem vamos
reclamar vamos fazer barulho com ninguém
vamos aproveitar todo mundo tem o
período de de referência eu hoje me vejo
muito no período do
nascimento pessoas acima do peso e
agradeço o momento procev pessoas acima
do peso que estão na passarela isso é
muito legal
e vocês já pararam pra perguntar em que
momento da história as pessoas com
deficiência se tornaram referência de
beleza coisa no ano de 2002
eu fui trabalhar num centro de
reabilitação para pessoas com
deficiência física e lá eu era fotógrafo
eu trabalhava no setor de fotografia
como chefe a minha função era fazer foto
para prontuário médico
foto de frente e costas do lateral
nequinha aqui do lado
nada de arte nada de glamour nu
artístico não existia e as pessoas ali
elas não se sentiriam humanas e eu não
me sentia a fotógrafa e fiquei me
perguntando o que eu estou fazendo aqui
então a gente precisou ali criar um meio
termo
comecei a fazer algumas fotos que o
prontuário médico de forma mais
descontraída levei alguns acessórios
espelho pente maquiagem bijuteria e
deixar uma pessoa à vontade pelo menos
durante cinco minutos pra ter contato
com a vaidade e depois fazer a foto
prontuário médico que era a valorização
da deficiência
não critico corpo médico sei que isso é
importante mas a pessoa realmente ela
não se sentia valorizado com algumas
brincadeiras que fazer no estúdio as
pessoas foram bem no que elas poderiam
ser referência de beleza então elas
começaram a me procurar fora do horário
de expediente para fazer multipessoal de
tanto bater na mesma tecla por isso que
eu falo que sou chata de tanto fazer
aquelas fotos se eu falasse isso bonita
não tem photoshop você usa foto na
lógica então não precisa muito é solos
maquiagem porque não ser modelo e a
gente começou a brigar por isso e nós
estamos falando do ano de 2004 para 2005
motivem as pessoas a irem atrás da dos
seus sonhos
a gente batalhou bastante e fomos atrás
de agências fomos atrás de produtoras e
as respostas eram sempre negativas
até que em um certo momento pesquisando
na internet
achei tudo na europa
o concurso a mais bela cadeirante é
reality show na frança e na inglaterra
estilo big brother brasil pessoas com
deficiência ea gente viu que ali estava
realmente essas oportunidades
e aqui no brasil só faltava um maluco
baixinho é invocada que pudessem apoiar
essas pessoas para irem atrás com elas
ai eu pergunto a vocês recentemente nós
temos na mídia alguns casos que as
atrizes do dia pra noite ficam
deficientes atual isso já é antiga
escola próxima foto primeiro fatal no
modelo eu não sei o nome e nem quer
saber de lingerie e vocês eu circulei
aqui como vocês podem perceber abaixo do
peito ela tem uma escoliose
mas essa escolha 11 é do photoshop volta
chocaram tanto a foto que deixaram a
menina sem um pedaço da gente pra quem
faltou chupar
eu tenho a renata paiva que está na foto
ao lado
ela é a menina de tango ela já tenha
escolhido ozzy que criávamos a pessoa
que tem uma funcionária de rondônia tem
24 anos e veio até são paulo com o sonho
de ser modelo e incentivamos ela não
fazer curso de teatro vão fazer curso de
expressão e hoje em dia a dia
trabalhando comigo como editoriais de
moda a próxima foto não sei se estão
percebendo mas pra mim é um cartaz o
exorcismo é aquela coisa se ele virar o
pescoço vai virando aquela coisa assim
toda a gente a gente pra que criar
pessoa com deficiência eu tenho pessoa
está pronto a trabalhar no mercado de
trabalho
a primeira pizza
alguém achou jogo do erro
alguém consegue ver o que o designer de
fotos e falei você contrata modelo paga
caro com o povo paga o cachê dela que é
visionário e aí se chama um design e o
que ele faz com a modelo
arranca vai dar a deixa a menina que
estava ali na prancha de trás pra que dê
novo criar o design chama eu tenho um
modelo certo para isso
eu tenho a mulher pronta frontera
espanha o modelo que a gente tem aí nós
temos hoje 89 modelos em território
nacional prontas para qualquer tipo de
atividade no campo da moda publicidade e
artes cênicas e finalmente uma modelo
pronto a gente ela já tá cadeira de
rodas dela já vai completa
ela tem paralisia cerebral ela vai
interpretar o editorial nome dela e
rayane hoje ela tem 24 anos e ela
trabalha comigo como modelo fotográfico
óbvio que ainda não dá pra viver as
pessoas com deficiência da modelagem um
preconceito existe infelizmente existe
a gente sabe que as pessoas ainda não
estão preparadas pra total diversidade
mas aos poucos a gente vai criando e uma
das coisas que eu gosto de falar é
justamente isso que a mídia dá espaço
para as pessoas com deficiência de forma
inconsciente
criando essa coisa no photoshop por que
não usar realidade
7 agora a outra parcela de culpa eu
também colocam as pessoas com
deficiência porque as pessoas ficam
naquela voltando à minha foto do rg
minha mãe fala que eu sou a coisa mais
bonita tinha na ponta da terra a gente
não pode esquecer que nem leite certo
então o que acontece se você quer ser
modelo
ok você vai acordar cedo você vai para
um curso de teatro você vai para o curso
de expressão e interpretação e tudo mais
não tem diferença
quem trabalha comigo sabe disso por isso
que eu falo pessoalmente invocada que
não cumprir as regras que são exigidas
no mercado de trabalho seja pessoas com
ou sem deficiência
você não vai ter oportunidade a gente
tem um sonho mas a gente não ir
além dele nada acontece então não
podemos colocar a culpa na sociedade com
o tempo todo e por último nós temos aqui
um mosaico com os nossos modelos adriana
mussolin karina carol paulo de olivença
se priscila - tim que é atriz
considerada pelo brasil a melhor atriz
ela tem 91 centímetros e aval que têm
ossos de milhas
aí eu falo para vocês o que a gente faz
todos os dias colocar esses
profissionais no mercado de trabalho e
uma dos nossos lemas é que beleza e
deficiência não são palavras ou poços
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]